[موسيقى]
عندما نذكر الهند واحده من الصور التي
تاتي في اذهاننا هي صور الافيان
[موسيقى]
فالفيل ليس مجرد حيوان في الحديقه ببلد
مثل الهند بل رمز مقدس للقوه والسلام في
المعتقدات الهندوسيه
[موسيقى]
في مدينه مثل جيبور لا زال البشر يستخدمون
الافيال لتجربه التجول داخل القلاع
الكبيره على ظهورهم ويحرصون على مشاركتهم
في المهرجانات ولكن ليس هنا فالمكان الذي
احدثكم منه اليوم يهتم كثيرا بتدليل
الافيال
[موسيقى]
منتجع كامل للافيال
هو منتجع اساسور بعدما عشى طفولته بين
احضان تلك الكائنات الضخمه ذات الحس
الفكاهي
بدات الى فانتاستيك في عام 2012 بهدف
انقاذ الافيال من الاستغلال التجاري في
المهرجانات والافراح والمعابد والسر لامنح
الفيل حياه الافيال الطبيعيه الحره
[موسيقى]
الافيال هنا تعامل معامله فخمه فالمنتجع
يحتوي على حمامات السباحه وحدائق واسعه
ومجموعه من العاملين الذين يهتمون براحه
الافيال وصحتها النفسيه
ولدت في عائله تمتلك افيالا فتربيت وسطهم
عندما كان هذا الفيل يبلغ من العمر اربع
سنوات كنت ابلغ انا خمسا وهو سر تعلقي بهم
واشعر انني محظوظ
[موسيقى]
كما ان المنتجع مفتوح لعشق الافيال الذين
يريدون قضاء يوم ممتع بشكل قريب منهم
فيستطيع الزوار المشاركه في تحميم الفيل
واطعامه واللعب معه ولكن ممنوع منعا باتا
ركوب الافيال
[موسيقى]
الناس يحتاجون المزيد من التوعيه حول حياه
الافيال فالكثيرون بمجرد سماع وجود فيل في
المكان كلما يفكرون فيه هو الركوب على
ظهره الفيل ليس وسيله مواصلات الفيل كائن
ضخم لكنه ايضا كائن حساس جدا يحزن ويتالم
نفسيا ويشعر بكل ما يحدث حوله
[موسيقى]
المساج والدايت ايضا من اهتمامات
اليفنتاستيك للافيال فيحضرون لهم بين شهري
فبراير ونوفمبر الشاباتي
ضياع عباره عن خبز بدون خميره ومضاف له
بعض البذور الهنديه التي تساعد على التخلص
من الوزن الزائد وتنظيم السكر وهي مناسبه
للبشر وللافيال ايضا لتعيش الافيال حياه
حره سعيده وصحيه لصباح العربيه ندى حجازي
الهند